civilisation tu bâtis ton royaume sur
des cadavres la violence des réactions
face à son texte prouve qu'il a fait
mouche
[Musique]
tu as vu ce noir est donc c'est un
journal pour un noir marron mais c'est
pain noir ça rené maran à bosser un noir
était sûr et puis voilà et on peut être
surpris dans les campagnes on peut être
surpris chez les bourgeois on peut être
surpris chez les français cultivent et
habitués à acheter des goncourt chaque
année
le petit parisien écrit c'est la
première fois que les noirs jouent et
gagnent
la polémique médiatique se transforme en
scandale politique
si le portrait d'un chef africain ne
choque pas la courte préface rédigée par
marrant elle met le feu aux poudres
en quelques phrases lapidaires
l'auteur jette une lumière crue sur la
réalité coloniale
civilisation tu bâtis ton royaume sur
des cadavres
vous avez vu sa préface mais c'est
horrible c'est une dénonciation de notre
patrie de la france du blanc de notre
action dans les colonies
personne avant lui n'avait écrit cela et
le coup est d'autant plus rude pour les
colonialistes que ce constat vient d'en
fonctionnaires de teyran la violence des
réactions face à son texte prouve qu'il
a fait mouche
lui n'a pas peur des mots les mots sont
là vous dire les choses et c'est ce
qu'il fait en fait chaque fois qu'ils
les crimes c'est qu'il donne justement
aux homos leurs vertus qui est justement
de dire la réalité des choses mais sans
fard sans masque sans mensonge je pense
que il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
savaient très bien ce qui se passe en
colonie les élites le savez les
gouvernants le savez les mais je pense
qu'il ya toute une partie de la
population qui l'ignoraient marron ne
cède pas
car il sait qu'il est dans le vrai
et les pionniers et l'histoire lui
donnera raison
si l'on va prebat walla le grand
écrivain andré gide prix nobel marche
sur ses traces
gide sillonnent plus de huit mois
l'afrique équatoriale française pour
saisir la réalité de l' empire colonial
il a pu confirmer il a vu que c'était
que c'était la vérité il est revenu le
dirai évidemment gîte était une très
grande figure dans la vie intellectuelle
en france et le fait qu'ils le disent à
a eu du poids ce qui caractérise cet
écrivain c'est en effet une constance
morale et intellectuelle
oh
il est l'un des premiers à questionner
en afrique comme en france les enjeux de
la négritude
quand senghor était jeune
il voyait en
redémarrant
un précurseur à nenê il avait beaucoup
de steam pour lui et il a toujours dit
des choses très belles sur lui de son
vivant et
après sa mort
[Musique]